yeah I was wondering like are you
starting to see the adoption of like the
woke uh inclusivity sort of alphabet uh
rainbow flag culture there yet no not
that that part isn't here no you know
they have ladyboys here yeah in the
comments asking about the lady boys I'm
not sure what they want to know but
yeah no ladyboys are amazing here they
they're they're men that want to be
women they dress like women they act
like women they act like women better
than women act like women in America
like an American man can come from
America and then come to Thailand and
see this like beautiful creature that's
like a 10 out of 10. and knows exactly
how to treat him sexually and
psychologically and I mean I've been
seduced by plenty of and even
tricked and I I welcome them if they're
so good that they can be more beautiful
than a woman and seduce me better than a
woman I'm okay getting tricked and and I
get a lot of criticism for saying that
of course that's interesting so I think
it's the opposite of gay I think what's
gay is being with an American woman who
acts more masculine than a man and uh
versus like a Thailand who's
super feminine and acts the femininity
even more than an American woman okay I
mean like I could see why somebody would
criticize me that so um and they don't
care about they don't care about like
their labels or their right they'll use
the women's bathroom and they look like
women and they act like women and the
women don't care at all because the
women see the ladyboys as them because
they they are acting exactly like
they're friends with them and and
ladyboys also because they have a little
bit of the male brain
they're smarter and they were better at
business and they're also more logical
so they're able to like work with women
and Lead women and let women follow them
and listen to them but they're also able
to like like you know be the liaison
between women and logic that's
interesting
um there's apparently some level of sex
tourism uh that goes on because there's
a demographic of ladyboys in Thailand I
think it's mostly Germans that are known
for wanting to visit and hang with these
dudes is that like what is that Avatar
about
well I I have been really shocked by the
amount of masculine successful
businessmen that love to take it in the
ass by ladyboys
that that that still surprises me I
don't feel anything gross about it I'm
just like wow really like
that's interesting
um yeah there's actually a book out
there if you guys want to uh learn a
little bit more about the underground
world of human degeneracy it's called a
billion Wicked thoughts uh and it talks
um about elements of that that that that
guys uh have fetishes around
um oh so can I okay I all wanted to
figure out what some of my fetishes are
because I'm 40 years old and I go
through life and then I figure out oh
this is a fetish God I wish I knew I
would have liked this 20 years ago and
you know learning by trial and error
means I got to go through a lot of stuff
I also don't end up liking I would I
would love to have like a checklist of
different fetishes is that what you're
talking is that like this book or would
give me that checklist I could try it I
would just say that it's a checklist
it's more of a dive into research and
study on human uh use of the internet
and search habits on Google and porn
sites and stuff like that to see what
fetishes come up so if you want to if
you want to dive into stuff that maybe
you haven't touched on uh you might be
surprised to find something in there but
it's but it's a pretty uh interesting
read of them okay what do you call it
because it does it's called a billion a
billion Wicked thoughts okay I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out